Now, before when we talked about parabolas, we said that changing the
coefficient out in front of the x squared changed the width of the parabola.
Putting a fraction out in front, like 1 3rd or one half, made the graph really
wide. And putting a bigger number like 2 or 3, a number greater than 1 as the
coefficient, made the graph skinnier, like we see in C and D. However, let's
think about this from a vertical point of view instead now. Instead of thinking
about these as making graphs wider or skinnier, we can think about these
coefficients actually making the graph taller or shorter. Changing this
coefficient, changes what the y value is going to be for any given x value.
Graph E down here, is our parent problem, y equals x squared. While we see that
point 2 comma 4, here. On graph B, we can see that when the x coordinate is 2,
the y coordinate is not all the way up at 4. It's only halfway as tall. You can
imagine that if I drew a vertical line going from the x-axis all the way up to
where the line meets the graph, we can compare how tall graphs are to one
another by picking the same x value and then seeing how tall that line is. How
many units in the y direction it takes to hit our graph. But, what determines
if a graph is stretching, like in graph D, or shrinking like in graph B?
Remember, this is in the y direction, the vertical direction. Something clearly
has to happen in their equations to make this happen in their graphs. let's use
good old y equals x squared, as our starting point, the function that we're
going to transform. When x squared, in this function, is multiplied by a value
that is greater than zero but less than one, will the graph be vertically
stretched or vertically shrunk? Now, on the other hand, if x squared is
multiplied by a value that is greater than 1, what will happen to the graph?